et on direct de lyon nous retrouvons
jean françois saluzzo expert en
virologie bonsoir pouvez-vous nous nous
rassurer car les prévisions de l' oms
sont alarmantes voir alarmiste je
rappelle que l'organisation parle de 100
millions de morts en cas de mutation du
virus
le chiffre est effrayant mais alors le
point essentiel dans la discussion
demeure la mutation du virus à l'heure
actuelle virus infecte
exceptionnellement l'homme et les
inrocks cas qui ont été rapportés aux a
vu par rapport à la quantité de
volailles infectées reste extrêmement
rare ce que craint le ms c'est une
évolution de ce virus cette évolution
peut se faire soit par mutation mais
surtout ce qu'on pense c'est qu'une
personne qui pourrait être infecté par
exemple avec le virus de la grippe
aviaire plus de virus de la grippe
humaine génère dans son corps un nouveau
virus qui soit ce qu'on pourrait appeler
humaniser c'est à dire qu'il se capable
de se transmettre d'homme à homme et qui
maintiennent ce pouvoir pathogène
exceptionnelle du virus de la grippe
aviaire selon les épidémiologistes
mauricio virus et ont montré si le virus
de la grippe aviaire oui comme il dit
rencontre celui de la grippe classique
que l'on connaît en france
est-ce que les conséquences pourraient
être aussi dramatique que celle de la
grippe espagnole par exemple en 1918
alors c'est très difficile de savoir si
le virus après cette recombinaison après
cette humanisation va devenir plus
pathogène ou va s'atténuer mais ce qui
inquiète beaucoup les autorités c'est
que les propriétés biologiques du virus
de la grippe aviaire sont semble-t-il
assez proche de la sévérité de la
maladie induites pendant la pandémie de
grippe
deux espagnols c'est pour ça que les
autorités sont très inquiètes ce virus
est exceptionnellement virulent en
portugais pour les animaux et maintenant
non seulement pour les volailles mais on
a pu montrer qu'il se transmettait
également par exemple chez les chiens
expérimentalement donc un changement
important dans l'épidémiologie de cette
maladie alors monsieur celle du zoo au
sein de sanofi pasteur ou travailler à
l'élaboration de deux vaccins humains
vous en avez déjà produit à titre
expérimental ce qu'ils sont efficaces
alors vous savez que lorsque la grippe
aviaire est apparu pour la première fois
en 1997
nous n'étions pas capables de produire
des vaccins tout simplement parce que
ces virus étaient que tu es les oeufs et
les vaccins sont produits sur des oeufs
entre 97 et 2004 des chercheurs ont
énormément travaillé pour mettre au
point une technique de génie génétique
qui a permis d'atténuer le virus de la
grippe aviaire et maintenant nous savons
produire du virus de la grippe aviaire
sur des oeufs
comme nous produisons chaque année le
vaccin de la grippe aviaire la question
qui se pose maintenant c'est de savoir
est-ce que ce vaccin produit dans des
conditions standardisés est aussi
efficace que le vaccin actuel carte avec
le virus de la grippe aviaire nous
tourner en situation un peu particulière
puisque la population qui va rencontrer
ce virus est tout à fait neil tout à
fait différente la situation actuelle où
chaque année invariants apparaît et
chaque année on vaccine mellal et la
population va être totalement naïve et
on se pose des questions de savoir si la
formule du vaccin actuel pourra être
efficace ou bien si on est obligé de
faire un vaccin surdosé ou adjuvé c'est
à dire avec un adjudant d'immunité ou
bien s'il faudra deux doses par exemple
de vaccins c'est ce que nous allons
maintenant étudier pour essayer de
qualifier définitivement ce bac saint
jean face à l'uso merci beaucoup d'avoir
été en direct avec nous pour ses
explications